régine est ce que vous avez gagné
beaucoup d'argent au cours de votre vie
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
vous avez fait quoi ah ouais je les ai
dépensé parce que c'est c'est vrai que
quand on gagne beaucoup d'argent et que
j'aime la fête quoi j'aime l'hospitalité
j'aime les chaussures j'aime les
magasins en compte comme un malade
il reste un peu de pognon quand même au
jeu doit rester bien en forme
oui vous avez investi dans quoi j'ai
investi dans ce que j'ai fait avec les
rsg investi dans sedan moi j'avais dans
mes habits j'avais dans la vie
aujourd'hui vous avez des bijoux de l'or
des actions des immeubles régime et si
oui non non rien du tout non je mettrai
pas d'appartement attendons une merde
même pas une chambre de bonne
vous avez quand même argent sur vous là
ce soir je dois avoir 30 euros vous avez
beaucoup d'argent sur votre compte
courant à la banque la non vous dépensez
combien par mois
j'ai dépensé jusqu'à des sommes
invraisemblables quelque chose je vais
parler en anciens francs belges décédés
dans ma signature
en tout entre 30 et 50 millions par jour
ah ouais 30 boîtes à travers le monde
si tous les gens à qui vous avez prêté
de l'argent vous le rende et là
maintenant ça ferait sofremi riches
ouais très très riches mais change de
trottoir vous allez emprunter de
l'argent ou déjà très peu qu est la plus
grosse somme d'argent qu'un homme vous
est donné ils ne m'ont pas de vide
argent jamais donc mon mari me dire une
tension progestine en garde le régime a
triomphé 00
les histoires